-Here at "Late Night" every
night, I deliver a monologue
comprised of jokes written
by a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk
that due to my being
a straight white male
would be difficult
for me to deliver,
but we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them.
So we'd like to share them
with you now in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
Hey, everybody,
these are two of our writers.
That's Amber right there,
and that's Jenny.
-I'm black!
-And I'm gay!
-And we're both women!
-And I'm not.
So, how this works is I will
read the setups for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go. A recent study shows
that computer algorithms
are more likely to mix up
black women's faces
than those of white women.
-But surely, it would
recognize me, Michelle Obama.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You are not Michelle Obama.
-You're right.
I'm Serena Williams.
-U.S. Women's soccer star
Megan Rapinoe announced today
that she will be
writing a memoir.
-Said lesbians,
"Will there be pictures?"
[ Laughter ]
-Focus Features
has released a trailer
for the new movie "Harriet"
about Harriet Tubman.
-It tells the unlikely story
of a black lady
who, against all odds, was
the main character in a movie.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, uh, Amber.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amber, who's, uh --
Who's playing Harriet Tubman?
-Me, Angela Bassett.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Mayor Pete Buttigieg
said recently that he is
almost certain that America
has already had gay presidents.
-I mean, you guys,
Abraham Lincoln
died at the theater.
-How are you so sure
Lincoln was gay?
-Because he had a beard.
Her name was Mary Todd.
[ Laughter ]
-A British woman
allegedly stabbed her boyfriend
after he tried to stop her
from packing so many clothes
for a vacation.
-Said the boyfriend,
"Ugh! That was my only shirt."
[ Laughter ]
-Now you're going to blame
that one on Angela Bassett.
"That wasn't me!"
A Conservative group
is calling for the boycott
of the movie "Toy Story 4"
because in the background
of one scene,
there are two lesbian moms.
-A lesbian mom
is like a straight mom
except she's ALWAYS
had that haircut.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. Which haircut?
-That haircut.
-[ Laughs ] All right.
10 police recruits
in Philadelphia were recently
caught trying to cheat
on an open-book exam.
-Said one officer, "Psst!
What'd you put down for
'Can you shoot
innocent black people?'"
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one?
-Oh, yeah, why not? After
Amber warmed them up for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on! Just do it!
-No, I feel like if I tell one,
it will not end well.
-Just one!
-Ohh, okay.
A couple in Michigan was charged
after animal-control officers
removed 178 cats
from their home.
178 cats?
Even lesbians think
that's too much pussy.
-[ Gasps ]
-How dare you!
-You told me it would be okay!
-You should be ashamed
of yourself!
-I am not! I'm proud of myself!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Give it up for these two,
everybody. We'll be right back.